I think what we need is we need to be
assured that it's going to be
independent we need transparency and we
need involvement of the key stakeholders
from groups that were impacted the most
and you know that's the bereaved
families clinically vulnerable parents
educational staff
um healthcare workers
um and you know the disabled community
so uh it needs to be something that
listens to those voices and delivers on
um us understanding how the the failures
during the pandemic had this devastating
impact on so many people in terms of
lives lost those bereaved long covered
impacts that will last for many many
years to come including on the NHS on
the economy and on our society
how prepared do you think we were for
the pandemic
I think we were very poorly prepared
that is very very clear what disturbs me
more than the poor preparedness during
the first wave is the fact that a lot of
the failures continued over time and
they weren't very clear just in
hindsight they were clear when they were
happening and they went against
scientific advice even at the time and I
would like to say those failures are
continuing now so in no way uh you know
are those things over we are in the
fourth wave just this year we continue
to see deaths we have two million people
living with long covered and we're
continuing to see people more and more
people believed uh particularly uh
people dying in in you know the
clinically vulnerable disabled and
elderly groups and I think we really
need to understand why that was allowed
to happen and it's continuing to be
allowed to happen of course the inquiry
won't address all of those parts but I
think if it addresses what happened at
least in the last few years uh we can
hopefully learn lessons from that moving
forward because I don't feel like that's
happened
and how concerned are you about future
waves
I mean very concerned we're obviously in
the middle of one there's absolutely no
reason we shouldn't continue to have big
waves we have new variants already on
the horizon that are expected to become
dominant within a few weeks and this
pattern is likely to continue unless we
take action in terms of air quality to
actually suppress
um infection going forward and you know
this will lead to unfortunately more
people living with long covet more
people disabled impacts on the economy
that we're already seeing and huge
impacts on the NHS which are already
apparent and people dying additionally
from other diseases because of that
his covid's still the threat it once was
so you know definitely the Threat Level
has reduced because we have vaccines but
is it still a threat absolutely so we've
had more than 24 000 deaths from covert
this Co which is more than what we have
in a whole year with influenza and
pneumonia not just influenza and in
terms of long covet it's caused
Devastation we have two million people
living with long covet many of them are
disabled the bank of England has warned
us that we have more people out of work
than we've had for decades before
suggesting this is also now impacting
the economy the healthcare services
absolutely on its knees I mean we have
people dying because they can't get to
the hospital in time and when they get
to the hospital in time they can't get
care in time I mean this isn't it's a
crisis unfortunately many people don't
realize it unless they're directly
impacted but if you have a stroke or
heart attack there's no guarantee you
can get
care in a you know in a timely manner
which is honestly terrifying and unless
we accept that we need to respond to the
pandemic rather than deny it I I really
worry that we will continue to have many
more people suffer and become disabled
over time